[APPLAUSE]
COEN VAN OOSTROM: Good afternoon.
This year is it's 20 years ago that I started in real estate.
And when I started in real estate, this man behind me,
he was the guy in real estate.
And he wrote a book, The Art of the Deal.
And that book was about deal making, and about making money, and making
buildings.
And to be really honest, I wanted to do that as well.
And to be more honest, if I would have known
that the guy was going in politics, I might have skipped it,
but that I didn't do.
And I started my company.
I started in Amsterdam.
And we built it, and we became quite successful.
We were, I guess, over the years after, one of the largest
developers in Western Europe.
But then 10 years later, now nine years ago, I met this guy.
Al Gore came to the Netherlands.
Al Gore had just written his book and made his movie.
And he was talking about global warming.
And to be honest, I wasn't that much of a tree hugger.
I wasn't so much of a green knight going around to making green buildings.
But he wasn't invited to speak at a breakfast meeting, organized
by a Dutch CEO.
And I was there as well.
And I was listening to him, and he had a beautiful metaphor.
He was talking about the dikes breaking in the Netherlands, which
for Dutch people is a big thing.
And the dikes breaking, he said, if that would happen,
that's not a political thing.
The people will stand shoulder to shoulder and fix it.
So why is this not happening when it comes to sustainability?
And there was a moment to ask questions.
And I raise my arm, and I said, so why are you talking to entrepreneurs?
Should you not be talking to governments, or to NGOs,
and they should talk about it?
He said no.
He said, the businesses will be the drivers for change
because if the businesses do not make new products like cars, or like planes,
or like buildings, then nothing's going to change.
And he looks at me, and what is it that you do?
I said, well, I've got a real estate company.
What can I do?
And he said, did you know that 35% of carbon emissions in the world
come from buildings?
I said, no, I didn't know that.
He said, but even more important, did you know that from every dollar
we spent on solving this carbon emission problem,
a dollar is best spent in the built environment.
And I said, what do you mean?
He said, well very simple, if you build-- if you build a windmill,
if you build solar panels, you always need a subsidy.
One day that will change, but for now, that's a real big thing.
But in the building environment, if you spend a euro,
there's a big chance that you will make it back in five or 10 years.
So it actually makes sense to invest in that sector, and you have a lot of work
to do.
So, I got really inspired, I got back to my office,
and I got all my people together.
Now, I have to tell you a little bit about my company.
My company was maybe more on the Trump side of things
then on the Gore side of things, to be really honest.
But we got some people together, and I said, we going to make green buildings.
And they we're not really convinced.
But one person raised his hand and said, hey, I never dare telling you,
but you know I studied physics, but I actually
am an expert in climate modeling.
And I used to work for Greenpeace, but nobody's
really interested in that story in this company, so I didn't tell you that.
[CROWD LAUGHS]
I go, OK, well, great to join the team.
So we start to work, and it turned out to be not that difficult to make
a sustainable building.
You just, from the beginning, have to look at that issue
that you want to solve.
And we started to do that.
Now, I could also see that some people in my company were not that convinced.
I was the boss so they would do it, but they're not really convinced.
And thought, I have to send a message.
Now for a real estate guy, the most important thing for him and his life
is his car.
People were driving BMWs, and they were very happy.
It's an ego thing, I guess.
And what I did is, I said, OK, we have to change this,
and I bought a Toyota Prius.
And I came to the office in my Toyota Prius.
And I said, guys we're going to sell all these old cars,
and everybody's going to drive these amazing car,
and we can actually see how much energy we use.
And that's going to be like a metaphor for what we want to do with buildings.
And they were not that happy.
[CROWD LAUGHS]
And one of these people, he took the car, and he went driving with it.
And he came back and he said, sorry Coen, I really--
I just don't like it.
And I became really upset.
And I said, this is important.
We have to change the world.
And what will our customers think if we come in an old fashioned car?
And he said, yeah, maybe you're right.
But I've got a better solution.
And the better solution is let's buy Minis
because the carbon emissions of a Mini is
104 grams CO2 per kilometer, which is exactly the same amount
as a Toyota Prius has.
Why not go the cool way instead of--
also an efficient way, but not so cool.
And so the funny thing was all these people in the Netherlands
were all very tall, and we were all in these small little Minis,
but that became sort of a funny thing.
So we started to do that.
And the nice thing was that even students would send those letters
and say, oh, we want to work for that company.
But it also became a metaphor for our buildings
because we figured out that if we want to make
buildings attractive with low emissions, we have to make them nice as well.
And the first building we made this building Las Palmas.
And we actually owned a warehouse, and we redeveloped, retrofitted
the warehouse.
And on top, we wanted to make this UFO-shaped building.
It became our home office.
And all the technologies that were available around us,
and that we knew from, let's say, universities and from companies
we worked with, we put in this building, so solar, and wind,
and all kinds of other technologies.
And it became one of the more, let's say,
one of the most sustainable buildings in the Netherlands.
And today I wouldn't say it's the world record,
but it was pretty good I had found it so good that I said to guys,
this building needs to be blessed.
And who else than the Pope can do that, so
let's ask the Pope to open the building.
[CROWD LAUGHS]
And it's a pity, but we actually asked bishop in Rotterdam,
and the bishop said, the Pope doesn't do buildings.
And then somebody said, well, let's ask Gore.
I said, well, we have-- we talked to him as well.
And we decided to ask Bill Clinton, President Clinton,
and he actually came over.
He opened the building, and he became a big ambassador of green buildings
and about this building.
So, the next step for us was that we wanted to do something really special.
We figured out there's so much more than we
can do than what we have done so far, let's go out there.
And we were lucky to have a tenant, Deloitte,
that said we want to have a building in Amsterdam,
and we want it to be the most sustainable building
in the Netherlands.
Now, the people in my company still were a little bit
on the Trump side of things, so they said, of the Netherlands?
The Netherland's not relevant.
Let's do the most sensible building in the world.
And I said, yeah, let's try that.
But then the question is, of course, how do you measure sustainability?
And it turns out in the world, there's a couple
of models of measuring sustainability.
There's a system in the US called LEED.
There's a German system, a French system.
But probably the most used system in the world is called BREEAM,
and it's a system from the UK.
And we adopted that system, and we knew there was a building in London that
had a score of 96%.
Theoretically you can go to 100%, but the maximum so far was 96%.
And we started to work.
And you must imagine, that if you want to do that, then the thing that
is happening is that you have to take all the decisions you take
in the development process, and everything,
you have to try to be sustainable as possible and put it in a model.
So if you order glass, or if you order concrete,
or even if you order the car for the guy who is managing the building site,
then that car has to be electrical because even that carbon
emission is going to go into the model.
And if you want to break the world record, it's not going to work.
And this is what the building looks like.
Let me push it again.
This is what the building looks like.
And it became a beautiful building.
But there was one little thing, we didn't make the 96%.
We got to 95%.
And the one thing missing in this model, the last couple of percentage,
is that you have to have so-called innovation credits.
So you need to do something that has never
been done before in the building industry
to get those last points in that BREEAM model.
And we went to talk to Siemens, and General Electric,
and start-ups in Berlin, and all kinds of other companies to see if somebody
had something that we hadn't--
that wasn't used before.
And we ended up talking to a Dutch company called Philips,
and they make LED systems.
And they had a LED system.
And you might say, well, LED, isn't that something that everybody uses?
That's true.
But they had a system where the LED doesn't
get its power from a normal 230-volt cable, but from an Ethernet cable.
And they call it "light over Ethernet."
And the great thing is that not only is the cable a lot more efficient
so you save energy, which was important for our model,
but the great thing is that an Ethernet cable is a two-way street.
So you can get data from that little light
and transport it back to a central computer.
Now that point, I didn't really get to at that time.
I was just happy that we got the credits.
And the building became 98%, and officially the Etch in Amsterdam
is now the world's most sustainable building, which is nice, right?
So at the day of the opening, these people that made it,
they gave me a book about big data.
And I heard about big data, but I wasn't really sure what it was all about.
But the sensors that you see here--
and we have 32,000 of those sensors in that building,
they measure all kinds of information.
Suddenly we can connect to your smartphone,
and we know exactly who is where in the building.
Now you might say, I don't really want people
to know where I am in the building.
But for a building manager, in the old days,
everybody would have his own desk, and we all know that roughly 30% to 40%
of desks in a building are not being used.
I'm not talking about the weekends, I'm not talking about the night,
but within working hours, they're not being used for so many hours.
And so if the building manager knows exactly who you are and where you are,
you can actually tell the computer in the morning,
you say, hey, I'm going to be working from home till 11:00.
From 11:00 to 2:00, I have meetings, well, I need a meeting room.
And then in the late afternoon what I want to do is read a contract,
so I need a quiet place.
And the building can then adapt to what you're doing.
Now, if a lot of people started doing that,
then the total amount of space that you save by doing that is 30%.
Compare that to what AirBnB is doing.
AirBnB is basically doing the same thing.
They use the inefficiencies that are around real estate,
and that we all know, and that is difficult to solve.
But information will solve that.
But then we found out that if you go in this whole world
of the Internet of Things, that there are
so many more things that you can do.
We have a cleaning company working for us.
And the cleaning company, the people working there, they have a little iPad.
And on their iPad, they can see exactly how often a toilet has been used.
They have a heat map where you can see if a floor has been used
or not, and whether that has to be cleaned.
Now in the old days, cleaning of a toilet
would happened typically at the end of the day.
But we all know that it's actually found that if the toilet has been used for,
let's say, 30 times a day, that it gets cleaned.
Now that is now possible based upon the information
that comes out of the building.
A whole different topic is the whole health in a building.
Its sort of weird that we are all OK with a building being in such a fashion
that we come in the morning at 9 o'clock, we leave at 5:00,
and at 5:00 we feel less healthy than when we came in.
The air quality is just not really great.
Now if you have 32,000 sensors in a building,
it's very easy to solve because you can, per floor or per square meter
see are people working here, or are they not working here?
Let's make sure that the air is going to the right places.
Let's make sure that if the windows need to be opened or not opened,
all these things can be done automatically.
And it's going to be a huge game changer.
Now this is just a start.
And the next phase is going to be even more
important because what happens if this is not happening on just one building.
What happens if we do that over a whole city?
Cities can be connected as well.
And what we see today is that a building like the Etch
is producing probably 10% more energy than it's using.
But that energy that is left over is then going back to the grid.
But this grid was built in the '70s, and is not an amazing grid.
Now, if we would have the smart grid, then the building next to it
can almost have a 100% efficiency in using that same energy that
was used by the other building.
But there are a lot more possibilities.
one other possibility could be that if the building knows
that there's a lot of meetings ending at 5 o'clock in the afternoon,
that there's a high likelihood of a lot of Ubers being collected as well.
And then with big data, the Uber people already
know that that is going to happen, and they
can be in front of the building instead of 10 minutes
or 15 minutes later, so endless possibilities in a connected city.
Has that been done before?
Yes.
This is a building that my company made in Rotterdam,
and it's called the Vertical City.
And within the Vertical City, we already experimented
with having apartments, hotel, offices in one building.
And we see that we can connect all these different functions in a building.
this is Berlin.
And this is maybe the difficult part of my story.
Why is it that all these buildings that you see in this picture
are actually not sustainable?
New buildings, relatively easy to solve.
Old buildings, a lot of work has to be done.
Now basically the message I have here today
is that the new technology and the big data possibilities that we have today
allow us to change these existing buildings also into smart buildings.
We just have to do a lot of work on it.
And we need real estate people and the city
to work together to make that happen.
I started my talk to speak about Donald Trump and his Art Of The Deal.
It was a little bit of a joke.
But there's also something serious.
Technology is not the problem to make our cities carbon neutral.
What we need is a deal.
And I think somebody and some of you should write a book,
and it's got to be not the Art Of The Deal,
but it's going to be the "Art Of The Climate Deal"
because we need some sort of deal between the owners of real estate
and the people who are governing our cities or our countries
to make sure that a lot of action is taken.
We have the obligation, and we can do it,
to step in and make all these buildings and these 35% of carbon emissions
coming from buildings going away.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]